[Music]
is that your puppy boom oh he looks a
little young to be in here you look a
little old to be in here Zeke was my
sister's ex-boyfriend he was the man and
he made me feel like man you meet some
punk and you'll have no idea is gonna be
parked in front of your house
every day for the rest of your life
[Music]
you're in high school you should be
making friends your own age you're
acting real something that chick is like
16 you're gonna get arrested Nick I'm 16
exactly what kids are supposed to make
mistakes that's what the whole point of
being a kid is smokes up to you and he's
never had an older brother you know I
think it's time
what you permanently inked tongue daddy
to your skin oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's dope Nashville yeah yeah it sort
of just looks like a bunch of scribbles
and dicks when you get older you realize
this kind of life is it's just scribbles
and dicks and violence halt and avoid
[Music]
Zeke was my sister's ex-boyfriend he was
the man you got a jerk off before you go
[ __ ] a girl I jerk off before I pick you
up
so it would be prepared I don't know
what the [ __ ] was going he made me feel
like the man home Rose gonna drink it
hold on what's in that whiskey beer
cough syrup and oh my do you meet some
punk and you'll have no idea at the time
that is gonna be parked in front of your
house every day
for the rest of your goddamn life you're
in high school you should be making
friends your own age I like hanging out
with you this weekend Paula's house it's
so hard you just saw my pot at your
party you think I'm just gonna walk into
a party and everyone's gonna want to buy
pot from me
call me crazy
[Music]
I'll act a little silly right now
alright that chick is like 16 years old
Nick I'm 16 exactly what kids are
supposed to make mistakes that's what
the whole point of being a kid is
you know I think it's time what doe you
permanently inked tongue daddy to your
skin what does that even mean oh my god
[Music]
you